qué es el periodo y la frecuencia bueno
el periodo es el número de segundos que
se necesitan para que algo complete un
ciclo o una revolución así que es un
proceso repetitivo y el periodo es el
tiempo que tarda en reiniciar ese
proceso y se mide en segundos
entonces la frecuencia es el número de
ciclos o revoluciones completados por un
objeto en un segundo es decir que el
número de veces que se repita el proceso
en un segundo será la frecuencia y se
expresa en unidades de 1 / segundo es
decir ects y como el periodo y la
frecuencia se definen como segundos por
ciclo o ciclos por segundo cada una es
la inversa de la otra es decir que el
periodo es igual a 1 entre la frecuencia
y la frecuencia es igual a 1 entre el
periodo y un ejemplo de un proceso
repetitivo es un objeto que viaja a
velocidad constante en este caso podemos
relacionar la velocidad del radio del
círculo y el periodo del movimiento
ya que la velocidad es igual a distancia
entre tiempo y la distancia que el
objeto recorre en un ciclo es 2 y por
earl por lo tanto la velocidad es igual
a 2 pi por el periodo y como 1 entre el
periodo es la frecuencia podemos
escribir la velocidad como 2 y por r por
la frecuencia y como el tiempo no es un
vector estas cantidades no pueden ser
negativas veamos un ejemplo supongamos
que una luna viaja alrededor de un
planeta en una órbita circular de radio
r a una velocidad constante ese y
queremos saber cuál es el periodo y la
frecuencia en términos de las cantidades
dadas y las constantes fundamentales
entonces usemos la relación entre la
velocidad el periodo y la frecuencia
vamos a ver
sabemos que para un objeto con
movimiento circular la velocidad es 2
pierce entre el periodo y eso significa
que en este caso el periodo es igual
2 r entre la velocidad y como la
frecuencia es igual a 1 entre el periodo
si sacamos el recíproco de esto
simplemente lo volteamos y nos queda la
velocidad entre 2 p
pero no podemos dejar nuestra respuesta
en términos de b tenemos que expresar
esto en términos de las cantidades dadas
y nos están dando s así que el periodo
es igual a 2 p r / s y para la
frecuencia nos queda ese entre 2 p r por
lo tanto la respuesta es la opción c
qué es la aceleración centrípeta la
aceleración centrípeta de un objeto es
la aceleración que provoca que ese
objeto viaje describiendo un círculo
ahora la aceleración centrípeta siempre
apunta hacia el centro del círculo y la
fórmula para calcular la aceleración
centrípeta es igual a la velocidad al
cuadrado entre el radio del círculo que
recorre el objeto y bueno aún cuando
esta es una fórmula extraña para la
aceleración sigue siendo una aceleración
y tiene unidades de metro entre segundo
al cuadrado y miren la aceleración
centrípeta si es un vector eso significa
que tiene una dirección va hacia el
centro del círculo y bueno la
aceleración centrípeta no provoca que el
objeto acelere y desacelere la
aceleración centrípeta solo cambia la
dirección de la velocidad pero si el
objeto que describe un círculo también
acelera o desacelera
también habrá aceleración tangencial
si el objeto describe un círculo y
acelera tiene que existir un componente
de la aceleración en la dirección de la
velocidad y si el objeto desacelera
habrá un componente de aceleración en
dirección contraria a la velocidad
entonces la aceleración centrípeta
cambia la dirección de la velocidad y la
aceleración tangencial cambia la
magnitud o el tamaño de la velocidad
pero esta fórmula de al cuadrado entre r
sólo nos da la magnitud de la
aceleración centrípeta y no tiene nada
que ver con la aceleración tangencial
veamos un ejemplo supongamos que la
partícula a viaja describiendo un
círculo con una velocidad constante ese
y un radio r si la partícula ve viaja
con el doble de la velocidad de a y el
doble del radio de a cuál es la
proporción de la aceleración de la
partícula
en comparación con la aceleración debe
bueno la partícula
de una aceleración centrípeta de la
velocidad al cuadrado entre el radio y
la partícula b también tiene una
aceleración de la velocidad al cuadrado
pero esta velocidad es el doble de la
velocidad de la partícula
y viaja describiendo un círculo con el
doble del radio de la partícula y
entonces 2 al cuadrado es 4 y 4 entre 2
es igual a todos por la velocidad de a
al cuadrado entre el radio de a así que
la proporción de la aceleración de la
partícula a en comparación con la
partícula p es un medio porque la
aceleración de la partícula a es la
mitad de la aceleración de la partícula
ve la fuerza centrípeta no es un nuevo
tipo de fuerza la fuerza centrípeta es
sólo una forma de clasificar a las
fuerzas que ya conocemos pero que
ocurren para que algo se mueva en una
trayectoria circular por ejemplo para la
luna que viaja alrededor de la tierra
edad es la fuerza centrípeta para un
yoyo girando sobre su eje en una cuerda
la tensión es la fuerza centrípeta para
una persona haciendo una pirueta sobre
su patineta la fuerza normal es la
fuerza centrípeta y para un coche que le
da la vuelta a una glorieta la fuerza de
fricción estática es la fuerza
centrípeta y estas fuerzas siguen la
segunda ley de newton pero si usamos
fuerzas centrípetas eso significa que
también tenemos que usar la expresión de
la aceleración centrípeta ahora si una
fuerza es dirigida radialmente hacia el
centro del círculo podemos decir que esa
fuerza es positiva ya que apunta en la
misma dirección que la aceleración
centrípeta y si una fuerza apunta hacia
afuera del círculo podemos decir que es
una fuerza negativa y si una fuerza es
dirigida tangencialmente al círculo no
la tomaremos en cuenta en este cálculo
para este caso usaremos be cuadrada
/ r para la aceleración centrípeta
entonces la fuerza tangencial cambia la
velocidad del objeto pero la fuerza
centrípeta cambia la dirección del
objeto entonces la fuerza tangencial
cambia la velocidad del objeto pero la
fuerza centrípeta cambia la dirección
del objeto veamos un ejemplo imaginen
una pelota de masa m que rueda por una
colina de radio r con una velocidad s y
en la cima de la colina queremos saber
cuál es la magnitud de la fuerza normal
aplicada por el camino sobre la pelota
bueno dibujemos nuestro diagrama de
fuerza tenemos una fuerza normal hacia
arriba y una fuerza de gravedad hacia
abajo desde la pelota hacia el suelo y
estas dos fuerzas no serán iguales y
opuestas porque si fueran iguales y
opuestas estarían en equilibrio y si las
fuerzas estuvieran en equilibrio el
objeto mantendría su velocidad y seguir
viajando en línea recta pero esta pelota
no viaja en línea recta y además acelera
al bajar así que la fuerza normal tiene
que ser menor a la fuerza de gravedad y
para calcular que tanto podemos usar la
segunda ley de newton junto con la
fórmula de la aceleración centrípeta
entonces la velocidad es s el radio es r
la fuerza de gravedad será una fuerza
centrípeta positiva porque apunta hacia
el centro del círculo y la fuerza normal
será una fuerza centrípeta negativa
porque apunta hacia afuera del círculo
entonces dividimos entre la masa y si
despejamos la fuerza normal nos queda la
fuerza de gravedad
- m por s al cuadrado entre r lo cual
tiene sentido porque la fuerza normal
debe de ser menor a la fuerza de
gravedad
la ley de la gravitación universal
formulada por isaac newton establece que
todas las masas en el universo jalan o
atraen a cualquier otra masa del
universo con la fuerza gravitacional y
esta fuerza es proporcional a cada una
de las masas e inversamente proporcional
al cuadrado de la distancia r del centro
al centro entre los dos objetos y la
forma matemática de esto dice que la
fuerza de gravedad o mejor dicho la
fuerza gravitacional es igual a g
mayúscula una constante que es igual a
6.67 por 10 a la menos 11 por las masas
en kilogramos entre la distancia del
centro al centro entre las dos masas ojo
no es la distancia de superficie a
superficie sino de centro a centro y
aunque estos dos objetos tengan
diferentes masas la magnitud de la
fuerza que apliquen una sobre la otra
será la misma y esto no los dice la
fórmula porque miren podemos
intercambiar las masas
obtendremos el mismo resultado ahora la
fuerza gravitacional si es un vector
tiene una dirección que va hacia donde
se encuentra la otra masa y bueno como
estamos hablando de fuerza la unidad es
newtons veamos un ejemplo supongamos que
dos masas las dos masas m ejercen una
fuerza gravitacional efe una sobre la
otra pero si una de las masas ahora es
de 3 m y la distancia de centro a centro
entre las masas es el triple cuál es la
nueva fuerza gravitacional bueno sabemos
que la fuerza gravitacional es igual a g
mayúscula por una de las masas por la
otra masa entre la distancia de centro a
centro al cuadrado así que la fuerza
inicial entre las dos masas nos queda
como g mayúscula por m por m entre r al
cuadrado y en la nueva fuerza cambiamos
una de las masas y nos queda como g
mayúscula x
3 m por m / 3 veces el radio al cuadrado
entonces 3 al cuadrado es igual a 9 y 3
entre 9 es igual a un tercio por g
mayúscula por m por m / r al cuadrado
por lo tanto la nueva fuerza es un
tercio de la fuerza original que es el
campo gravitacional bueno el campo
gravitacional es otra forma de llamar a
la aceleración causada por la gravedad
en un objeto y podemos visualizar el
campo gravitacional como vectores
apuntando radialmente hacia una masa
todas las masas crean un campo
gravitacional que apunta radialmente
hacia ellas y la fórmula para la fuerza
gravitacional g creada por una masa m es
igual a g mayúscula por la masa que crea
ese campo entre la distancia desde el
centro de la masa hasta el punto en el
que queremos determinar el valor del
campo
y este valor del campo gravitacional
será igual al valor de la aceleración
causada por la gravedad de un objeto que
se encuentra en ese punto ahora el campo
gravitacional es un vector tiene una
dirección que en este caso va hacia el
centro de la masa que lo crea y bueno
como el campo gravitacional es
equivalente a la aceleración causada por
la gravedad la unidad es metros por
segundo al cuadrado o también puede ser
newtons por kilogramos que es otra forma
de saber a qué se refiere el campo
gravitacional pues no solamente es la
aceleración causada por la gravedad de
un objeto en este punto sino que también
es la cantidad de fuerza gravitacional
aplicada sobre una masa m que se
encuentra en este punto así que podemos
pensar en el campo gravitacional como la
fuerza gravitacional por kilogramo de un
punto en el espacio y si lo reordenamos
nos queda que la fuerza de gravedad es
igual a m por g
un ejemplo supongamos que un planeta
hipotético x tiene tres veces la masa de
la tierra y la mitad del radio de la
tierra cuál es la aceleración causada
por la gravedad es decir la fuerza
gravitacional en el planeta x en
términos de la aceleración causada por
la gravedad de la tierra
bueno sabemos que el campo gravitacional
de la tierra es igual a g mayúscula por
la masa de la tierra entre el radio de
la tierra al cuadrado y a esto le
llamamos g subíndice entonces el campo
gravitacional en el planeta x es igual a
g mayúscula por tres veces la masa de la
tierra entre la mitad del radio de la
tierra al cuadrado y si elevamos esto al
cuadrado nos queda un cuarto en el
denominador y tres entre un cuarto es
igual a 12 por qué mayúscula
la masa de la tierra entre el radio de
la tierra al cuadrado por lo tanto como
todo este término es la aceleración
causada por la gravedad de la tierra la
aceleración causada por la gravedad en
el planeta x es 12 veces la de la tierra
muchas veces cuando resolvemos problemas
gravitacionales puede que nos den la
densidad en lugar de la masa y la
densidad es la cantidad de masa por
volumen de un cierto material el símbolo
para la densidad es la letra griega ro y
la podemos calcular simplemente
dividiendo la masa entre el volumen así
que la unidad para la densidad es
kilogramos por metro cúbico y no es un
vector porque no tiene dirección ahora
para calcular la masa si conocemos la
densidad podemos decir que la masa es
igual a la densidad por el volumen
veamos un ejemplo nuevamente tenemos el
caso del planeta hipotético x pero esta
vez en lugar de que el plano
tenga tres veces la masa de la tierra
supongamos que es tres veces más denso
que la tierra y que sigue teniendo la
mitad del radio de la tierra cuál es la
aceleración causada por la gravedad en
el planeta x en términos de la
la tierra
bueno sabemos que el campo gravitacional
de la tierra es g mayúscula por m / r al
cuadrado pero esta vez no conocemos la
masa del planeta x solo conocemos la
densidad entonces vamos a reescribir
esta fórmula en términos de la densidad
simplemente sustituimos m porro por b
porque acuérdense que la densidad es
igual a la masa entre el volumen por lo
tanto la masa es igual a la densidad por
el volumen pero tampoco conocemos el
volumen en este planeta sólo conocemos
el radio así que vamos a describir el
volumen en términos del radio porque
sabemos que los planetas son esféricos
y el volumen de una esfera es cuatro
tercios por pi por r al cubo entonces si
sustituimos esta expresión en el volumen
nos queda que la aceleración causada por
la gravedad o el campo gravitacional g
es igual a g mayúscula borro por cuatro
tercios por pi por r al cubo entre r al
cuadrado
así r al cuadrado se cancela y nos queda
que g minúscula es igual a g mayúscula
borró por cuatro tercios por pi por r y
sabemos que la aceleración gravitacional
de la tierra es igual a g mayúscula por
la densidad de la tierra por cuatro
tercios por pi por el radio de la tierra
y la aceleración gravitacional del
planeta x es igual a g mayúscula por la
densidad del planeta x que es tres veces
más denso que la tierra por cuatro
tercios por ti por el radio del planeta
x
es un medio del radio del planeta tierra
y si factor izamos todo esto nos queda
tres medios por la expresión de la
aceleración causada por la gravedad en
la tierra por lo tanto la aceleración
gravitacional del planeta x es igual a
tres medios por la aceleración
gravitacional del planeta tierra las
órbitas gravitacionales son un caso
especial de aceleración centrípeta en la
que cuando un cuerpo órbita alrededor de
otro debido a la fuerza de gravedad si
esa órbita es circular podemos
relacionar a la velocidad el radio de la
órbita y la masa usando la segunda ley
de newton y la aceleración centrípeta
pues simplemente sustituimos la
aceleración por la aceleración
centrípeta de cuadrada entre er y como
la fuerza centrípeta es la fuerza de
gravedad podemos sustituir la expresión
de la fuerza de gravedad por la fuerza
centrípeta que es g mayúscula por m por
m /
la distancia al cuadrado así la masa del
objeto que está orbitando se cancela y
nos queda una expresión que relaciona a
la velocidad de ese objeto con la masa
que lo atrae y la distancia de centro a
centro entre los dos objetos y si
despejamos b nos queda que b es igual a
la raíz cuadrada de g mayúscula por la
masa del objeto grande el que atrae
entre la distancia de centro al centro
entre los dos objetos y observen que
esta fórmula no depende de la masa que
se encuentra en órbita porque se canceló
anteriormente veamos un ejemplo imaginen
que una estación espacial de masa ms
orbita a una altitud de 13 r sobre un
planeta de masa mp y de radio r como se
muestra en este diagrama pero después
imaginen que una estación espacial
diferente de masa 3 m/s orbita a una
altitud de 12 r sobre un planeta
de más a 4 mp y de radio 2 r como vemos
en este diagrama y queremos saber si
cuando la velocidad de la estación
espacial de masa ms es p entonces en
términos de ve cuál es la velocidad de
la estación espacial de masa 3 m/s bueno
ya vimos que la velocidad de un objeto
en órbita es igual a la raíz cuadrada de
g mayúscula por la masa del objeto
grande que atrae al objeto pequeño entre
la distancia de centro al centro que hay
entre los dos objetos y como esta
fórmula no involucra a la masa del
objeto que se encuentra en órbita
no importa si esos objetos tienen
diferentes masas pero la masa del
planeta si puede hacer una diferencia
así que la velocidad de la estación
espacial de masa ms es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de g mayúscula por la masa del
planeta p / la distancia del centro al
centro que observen que no es igual al
del planeta oa la altitud sino al radio
del planeta más la altitud porque
recuerden que tiene que ser la distancia
de centro a centro entonces en este caso
3 r más r es igual a 4 r ok y la
velocidad de la estación espacial de más
a 3 ms es igual a la raíz cuadrada de g
mayúscula por la masa del planeta que en
este caso es 4 mp entre la distancia de
centro a centro que en este caso es 12 r
+ 2 r nuevamente es 4 ver entonces si
comparamos las dos estaciones la única
diferencia es que aquí tenemos un 4
extra y como la raíz cuadrada de 4 éstos
nos quedan dos por la expresión de la
velocidad de la estación espacial ms así
que la estación espacial 13 ms viaja al
doble de la velocidad de la estación ms